schon wieder alarm in der liebig 34 vor
knapp zwei wochen rückte die polizei mit
einem großaufgebot an und räumte das
besetzte haus in der berliner
liebigstraße 34 am mittwochabend brach
vor dem gebäude ein feuer aus szene
anhänger hatten vor dem gebäude kerzen
aufgestellt
diese standen in unmittelbarer nähe zum
lager den sperrmüll ob sie das feuer
entfachten oder ob es sich um
brandstiftung handelt ist noch unklar
die flammen schlugen meterhoch auch das
erdgeschoss brannte
zur ursache machte der sprecher noch
keine angaben
gegen 22 uhr war der brand gelöscht um
das haus liebig 34 einem symbol der
linksextremen szene war lang heftig
gestritten worden
mitte oktober wurde es unter protest
geräumt bei einer demo der szene kam es
in der folge trotz großen
polizeiaufgebots zu gewaltausbrüchen
matthias lukaschewitsch ist für uns vor
ort an der liebig 34 guten morgen
matthias wie konnte es zu dem brand
gestern abend kommen
das ist nach wie vor ein wenig unklar
die polizei geht inzwischen von
vorsätzlicher brandstiftung aus ich habe
noch einmal rücksprache gehalten einen
informanten bei der polizei es ist davon
auszugehen dass wegen schwerer
brandstiftung und schweren
landfriedensbruch ermittelt wird also es
ist mitnichten so dass hier kerzen diese
sogenannten wo die katzen die hier neben
mir stehen sie vor dem gebäude an der
liebig straße stehen dass die ideen
waren möglicherweise verursacht haben
könnten das ist barer unsinn wird das
haus denn überhaupt jetzt noch bewacht
im moment ist eine polizei einen
polizeiwagen es da mit acht mann und
acht polizisten bewacht ja zumindest
sind sie vor ort und sie gucken ob jetzt
hier heute noch was passiert im moment
ist es auf jeden fall sehr ruhig er das
haus wurde ja vor zwei wochen geräumt
also wieder seinem besitzer damit
übergeben der ja auch verantwortlich ist
wie geht es jetzt weiter mit diesem haus
irgendwie reißt der streit und die
kochenden emotionen reißen nicht ab
vermutlich wird wird hier wirklich im
wortsinne wird immer wieder irgendwas
entfacht werden das heißt ein brandsatz
stimmung die gemacht wird
demonstrationen anschläge auch in der
näheren umgebung autos werden ja
angezündet auch in den nachgang zu der
demonstration nach der räumung brennen
hier ja immer wieder autos es ist unklar
ist es sind bauarbeiter in der im rausch
die versuchen sich wahrscheinlich da
durchzukämpfen und zu sanieren aber sie
sehen ja hintergrund ist der hinter mir
der ganze bau studie liegt ob dieses
haus möglicherweise irgendwann einmal
dem den besitzer übergeben werden kann
in den sanierten zustand das halte ich
für völlig offen im moment
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren